no holy [ __ ] hi Lisa Lisa Lampanelli you
too you look really good oh yeah yeah
sometimes they give you really [ __ ]
assignments they do right yeah I mean
really is there I mean there's there's
not that much radio in general in New
York that's worth right doing like Elvis
has a giant audience yeah only when I do
I think right I just serious and Elvis
and I I don't think I've done a radio I
did used to like hot 97 in that but that
was when I was into the black guys does
that help you draw uh no damn fries by
God no that's my life you know but yeah
now that I'm skinny they don't want me
on anymore because I don't [ __ ] the
blacks
oh yeah Jim knows he knows that big ass
so they have something to hide behind
when the cops start using this or I
understand that's affected how do you
how is being the political correctness
which I know you for so long
yeah and in the last three years for
years it's gotten astronomically worse
how has it affected you like not in the
least and can I tell you why I'm not a
big tweeter and a big Facebook or and
all that I I'm at 56 years old I don't
need to do that it makes my life
miserable so I do it if I have to but so
that way I don't get in trouble
however on stage it's my audience coming
they expect it they expect the n-word in
the c-word and all that stuff I don't I
don't sprinkle the n-word in as much
because that was my one Twitter problem
I instagrammed a picture this was so
embarrassing I instagrammed a picture of
me and Lena Dunham saying me and my ni
GGA right you thought I got all Jade
Lisa's cool enough to pull that off
though it was within the last three
years and everybody went nuts what I
know so I said I this Wendy Williams
came after me I hurt hurt my feelings
that wasn't mad I just was like oh I
made a mistake I'm yeah I mean colossal
[ __ ] yeah so what I did was I didn't
apologize but I went on Wendy and said
you know if it hurt an individual's
feeling I'm sorry I said the joke but I
don't apologize to groups right you
can't polish a group dude the other day
this and honestly I felt no remorse
about this an old man like literally
probably 75 years old when I started
doing some jokes about autism kids
because I [ __ ] can't stand them like
I really
I really like Down syndrome kids I'm
totally down with the noun but let me
tell you something I'm sick of these
freaking would he go autistic yes oh
they spoiled my game night because
they're focused on lists and there I'm
trying to play apples apples with you
little [ __ ] right I got a freaking
worried about you going off on a tangent
now we got to be for a lot politeness
stick with it
anyway right now I get this so I did a
bunch of what system jokes that I think
are terrific well this guy literally had
been laughing the whole show 75 years
old men shut down like you just tell
when somebody shuts down sure he didn't
yell he wasn't who was gentlemanly he
just sat there and I said to him you
know tickly no more like he had empathy
and I said you know sir I can't help but
notice I remember his name I can't
remember but I had used his name a lot
for the old people joked I said are you
okay you kind of shut down and he's like
yeah because um you know those kind of
hurt me because I adopted two autistic
kids and first of all I want to say that
your [ __ ] problem but I honestly went
in my heart because I've kind of
discovered my heart in the past few
years I said honestly if it hurt your
feelings I apologize I want to meet you
backstage because I was like I really
want to talk to this guy
so Jimmy I'm sure you're like this
you've no problem with an individual
gentlemanly or womanly saying to you
look it hurt me and here's why but I had
to a group they could suck it I honestly
feel that way I'm not being all brave
because I really do you understand me
yeah because once it was because it
could just be one person the group
speaking for the group but an individual
speaking for themselves
yes but I've thought about you a lot in
the last couple years ago wonder how
this is going up for people know who you
are they know what you do right
so what about you Griffin though job you
have a captive violent image of a
president that was it that was different
for any comments on schism do you also
feel this way because I've every
interview now I'm asked about the Kathy
Griffin thing so of course and honestly
the only thing I really feel is if there
was a punch line attached it would have
been okay to some people yeah because
you know funny is funny that's kind of
my job it just didn't have anything that
I could grab on to right like I'm
politically correct as [ __ ] but if I saw
that I was still like whoa what's going
on here but if there was a funny thing I
might be like oh I understand what she's
trying to say I said I'm politically
correct as fine I mean aggressively
apologize you know I'm wowed by
you know I always had a little crush on
Norton and I'm going to tell you why
what he resembled Don Rickles to me and
I always had a big thing for Don Rickles
but not sexually like I kind of admired
him so much and he was such a great guy
and so Norton kind of remind me a little
and it was never anything really sexual
crush but I'm like oh if Norton was
normal like Rickles for that appropriate
mate for me but god damn it he's creepy
and weird you understand whether I have
some self-esteem left right you know but
you're very cute so I'm out and I'm
misspeaking right Sam on the other hand
man okay neither am i am 56 what am I
going to do I'm skinny now you make me
laugh so hard I forget what Rosie I
might have been the gene Simmons but
you're saying how ugly the days was well
Jim Norton why don't want me to do the
job can I tweet it out I was going to do
my favorite joke and your favorite joke
from the gene Simmons I go Jim Norton
you ugly bastard yes you know the dais
is ugly when they invite Jim Norton to
be I can see and you know funny line but
guess what's good about you though you
said can you can I use this joke in my
book as my favorite roast joke from that
thing and I was so honored you know
because we always want other comics your
admire to look like us
sure and whenever I'm asked about my
heroes they always ask me what these
[ __ ] women I can't stand it you don't
like lady comment yeah you know what
none of them ever make me laugh from my
gut you know what I mean new ones yes
but these old established [ __ ] I don't
care about you don't like they always go
who do you like and I don't care if they
never heard of these people I always go
David tell Jim Norton this one that one
because those are the guys that I always
sit in the back of the cellar in the old
days and would laugh my CEO off I just
thought it was hilarious when you guys
would go up there Oh until David tell
one time I never told this he yelled at
me for laughing at him and I was like
this [ __ ] I'm laughing my ass off and
he goes oh yeah laughs and Ellie it's
not about you
oh well you don't even know what you got
if you want to see Lisa she'll be
outside the cellar whipping a slave with
a gun Rickles album fantastic
you'll get no better than that put your
first political correctness that got my
audience knows they're coming to see
that and they don't okay I'm bracing you
don't get worried that something's going
to bring a phone out take it out here
I'm thing out of context dude worse is
out there what I said on on my show I
remember you know I hesitate to say this
word but I'm doing a quote for myself
two specials ago I think I said
something like oh you guys want to hear
my new cut off my new album it's
dropping Thursday on Black History Month
it's called [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
comes good [ __ ] here like it's not
even a joke no what I was like if you
want to see those horrible words just go
online you're going to see them but
that's funny and you're obviously just
being ridiculously over-the-top and
thank you doesn't get that yeah well
that's what I learned from Rickles too
which is if you say something they get
so obviously stupid but no one could
believe you mean it like when he said
without Mexicans there would be no filth
to me that joke is so like cut and
bloody it couldn't dried nobody could
believe that I mean serious it's the
blacks with the fence I don't know
because he know he knew I learned from
him how to really do a joke like that
what motivated you because you you you
went to such a transformation asked the
exact same question
what was this moment of clarity where
you're like the weight has to come on
because you obviously have struggled
before boy thirty two years from the
time I'm 18 to 50 up and down up and
down and it happened because I talked
about this in my play we talked about
the fact that I went to college I was
skinny throughout my life at 18 I go to
college miserable I wasn't ready to go
away and I yes I wasn't date raped I
didn't have any huge trauma I didn't
have to go on Milan order a special rape
show with Mariska Hargitay every day on
you I say all day sure sometimes even I
on TV well but it was horrifyingly I was
out of place I didn't fit in so the
eating became my friend yeah so I
decided at age 50 after 32 years ago an
up and down I said enough and you can
look in a mirror and you can say okay
I've tried every diet and exercise plan
it doesn't work this is the only way to
do it
and thank God I've kept it off for five
years which you know I didn't want to
gain it back because in the
that's known as pulling a carnie Wilson
or a Ralphie may yes and I don't want to
do that I love you Ralphie if you're
listening which I'm sure you are
Jonah Hill oh yeah and he didn't even
have a stomach cut out no mine I think
they cut it out
75% your stomach just goes really yeah
see really small portions the rest of
your life and you have to deal with your
problems instead of using a substance
what would always happen like you start
losing weight I'm sure and they're
usually tweaking of one or two bad days
they got [ __ ] like what was right
what would set you off mine was my
shrink said to me when she goes I think
you think the weight first of all is
helping you disappear for men it's
helping you you know protect yourself
from guys and from attention and then I
become a [ __ ] stand-up so I clearly
want some kind of attention shows well
the weights surance and helpings we'll
want to just get rid of it and like yeah
but it's so hard like even me and Jimmy
big balls when we were married
we went to Weight Watchers one last time
and we go we lost seven pounds and I
think it scared us that this is going to
be a change this is going to be a huge
thing in the rest of our life so we just
had [ __ ] it and we went to a diner
really yeah I would always just screw it
up and I go I need something that like
with an alcoholic wouldn't be the best
if there was an operation you could have
as an alcoholic that limited you to one
drink a day right that's what this
surgery is it's a weird thing like and
it sounds they just reminded me
something when I was a kid I did human
growth hormone because I was so small
hmm and like the struggle that I had
mentally I remember I was like 12 or 13
or whatever and I had been the short kid
for so long like for my entire life that
I was like if I do this and I'm not the
short kid anymore I don't know what you
are done what I am Sam is riding this
sure I've owned it I've identified it a
nice thing everybody knows it and it's
like I want to be average height but
like it's an unknown territory not Who I
am right and and and it was this it that
that thing of like you are the fat
comedian right right now it's like how
am I not going to if I'm not the fact
comedian in him anymore then what am I
going to be our attire yeah I think I
got to a certain age because I get to 50
I think 52 I did it right after
Celebrity Apprentice I was like well I'm
ready to retire if I can't be funny
anymore as a normal sized person and
I get the friggin surgery I get
obviously horrifyingly beautiful from
the neck down
I'm freaking terrific but and then
you're still got what you got from the
neck up you know I've never been in a
beauty contest and I'm 66 so I go oh I
could still make fun of other things I'm
still emotionally codependent I still
work on my stuff so the audience still
knows that there's things that they can
you know that you really don't like
about yourself that you can't change
yeah why did you stop doing the Comedy
Central Roast do they ask you they not
ask you anymore excuse so what else what
happened Bob Saget one I had said I
couldn't do it and I told them why I
just gotten out of this 28-day food
rehab I told you I tried everything I
really have for this yet and I just
wasn't in the mood to do the roast it
was literally a week after and I'm like
I can't I was just in something really
intense so they asked me then to do the
Joan Rivers one and I had gone through a
similar program the next year I go I
can't do it because it's not worth it
unless I'm roastmaster they said no
because Kathy Griffin did it I said okay
then so I do the Trump one they asked me
to do the frankandcharlie shame and this
is what happens when you start to get
emotionally open like oh no no no I
can't
it would seem like I'm making fun of
someone who has mental problems so I
just can't
I can't morally do it - are we shame
yeah so Amy Schumer says to me now like
a couple years ago she said thank God
you turned that down because I did it
and then after that they like didn't ask
me to do anymore and I go Amy it's not
meant to be any more if you lobby to get
back on the myrrh ask I didn't want to
get on the James Franco one I there was
another one I did Oh beaver I don't
think I asked them but there was one
maybe it was beaver that my agent said
you know what Lisa will come back if you
want and it didn't happen I think that
was universe's way of telling me you've
done already you know Norton let's be
honest with you you never seen a [ __ ]
roaster like me they were great I was
Jeff Ross I loved him but he could suck
my [ __ ] I'm Way better if you're
listening Jeff which you are you dirty
Jew you know I love you but no you know
that I nail it and I think it's when you
go I've done it all in that area what's
there left well I say you know it's
almost to pay so I've seen better rugs
in the back of a rape van by the great
house a [ __ ] sledgehammer line oh I
well you know what I had that staffer
writers and I would come up with the
jokes and then we try to punch them
offshore and one of my guys this was the
best he goes to me Lisa I'm sorry
after that Pam Anderson roast every one
of them has to be a haymaker he goes you
cannot have even one that's a B or an
a-minus and we I would work my ass off
for like a month on this thing that's a
lot of work on a roast yeah and you'll
now the fryers of course always ask me
to do theirs
and they're not televised so part of me
is like I [ __ ] love you guys but I
mean unless it's going to be somebody
huge why am I going to do this right I
like press I like a lot of hits I don't
like to have this where I do all the
work for nothing
but I'll do charity it's a lot of
charity it seems to like Comedy Central
though it's not where it used to be Duff
it was the Friars Club on Comedy Central
and now it's more like it feels like
it's cast meaning how they get a
celebrity who's going to bring some
celebrity friends there's usually one
female comic yes that is there to be the
breakout female comic for Comedy Central
right and then there's you know there's
the one there's Jeff Ross is there so we
still say well you don't know it's about
one of the producers now I know but I
always thought it was bizarre that they
didn't have Norton and depalo more
they'd only use me once and that was at
Bob Saget's request on his row I did
have to request it almost now these big
shots yes so they never they never gave
me a lot of those I don't know why but I
kind of accepted it to like you just
want to that's what I always goes
whatever's meant to be meant to be you
should have seen me today right before I
came in here I didn't know it was you
guys because I don't know I thought it
was still okay I'm freaking [ __ ]
I don't read I don't read the paper so
I'm in the car I'm like Jim and Sam
little [ __ ] thing I got to do this
one I got to do that Luzerne this one
well then I come and I find out you so
I'm in the worst mood and then I get in
a better mood to it's the universe's way
of taking care of me
yeah so sometimes you just got to go let
it go and by the way when I wrote my non
best-selling book chocolate please that
was a huge disappointment because I
wasn't a best-seller I was so sad and I
wrote um years ago like about almost ten
years ago now and that started the big
shift of like if whoever needs to read
this will read it like find it yeah
whoever needs to come see a show will
and that's how I have to feel about
everything because we will
honestly kill ourselves yeah we forget
that like our problems as performers oh
I didn't get enough people there I take
most people like would you shut the [ __ ]
up
just [ __ ] you flying business class
you want to shut your mouth I know yes
but you know what I think it is it's the
pressure we put on ourselves it is rich
people problems and white people
problems for sure like it's never going
to be like oh my god I'm just grateful
to have limbs yeah you know hey you know
what if I didn't have limbs I'd probably
be more [ __ ] famous because I'd be a
crippled atomic I feel terrible like a
head a head in a torso who wouldn't go
see that [ __ ] they were mad about that
right but it's the fact is you know we
put it all on ourselves and it is it
feels heavy
you will feel sad it feels like oh my
God my suppose my numbers aren't what
they used to be and I remember my UJ day
before I even had any change of weight
or life or anything was when I sold out
Radio City and Carnegie Hall within
three months of each other and I think
that was the top and I go will I have a
resurgence where I could do that again I
don't know but in the meantime you gotta
let go of expectations and just have a
good time and say whoever's going to
find me well you know we it's corny to
say peaks and valleys I remember working
with guy I worked with David and dice
took me it was after the arenas we was
doing like three four thousand people I
mean they were maniacs sure he had an
amazing career but he was obsessed with
getting back into the garden and arenas
and I always sit on the answer you don't
seem to understand like where you're at
like okay not the garden but your
[ __ ] do it 3,000 people a night and
they're [ __ ] psychotic and they look
like right and now we've got the show on
Showtime so he went ahead and went back
up high yeah but people forget sometimes
like where you are is still better than
most of the people you started with just
be grateful for you are what they say
about gratitude resentment can't coexist
with gratitude so if you're sitting
there going oh my god I'm so lucky that
I flew business clancer I'm so lucky
that I had a car pick me up instead of
having to get in one of those smelly
[ __ ] who I'm going to write badly from
this morning you just own yourself oh my
god how can I resent where I am if I'm
grateful for where I am so those are two
principles that can't exist in the same
place did you get super sensitive but
you're saying like around that Charlie
Sheen time did you get sensitive
yourself oh my god ever since
that food rehab with the Zagat when I
turn down this agarose I started
chipping away on my real problems and
why was eating and why I was dating
inappropriate men and why I you know I
got married to Jimmy big balls and even
though he's a great guy and we're still
thank God good friends and had an
amicable divorce I was like oh I'm
finding out what I really want and what
really drives me and what I don't like
about my life so I think yeah all that
stuff open job right there and I went
and I frickin made the mistake or slash
blessing of getting a rescue dog and
those [ __ ] really open you up because
I always have this joke now Jim where I
swear to god I could be on the phone
screaming at my [ __ ] Jew agent I'll
be like you [ __ ] I mean Oregon
how dare you two hours from the airport
the dog walked in my clothes never bite
and then you start doing it to your
friends so I think what happens is your
heart opens up more yeah and you become
a better person but on stage you could
still get all the crap out that's what I
like about my life now it was good kids
know can I tell you what I'm warned a
few years ago that I didn't have
grandkids because I never wanted kids
but now when I see my friends having
grandkids I'm like so jealous
well my spiritual I know that sounds
super gay but my stuff's one of my
spiritual leader said to me why don't
you just pretend your nieces and nephews
or your grandkids and treat them like
you would a grandmother like [ __ ] a
right pay for the wedding like I love
that
and it's really shifted again gratitude
for what I got I got these eight nieces
and nephews why not be great with them
the anger is such a good tool as a
comedian too because it fuels so much of
what we do yeah but as you get older
it's harder to maintain it unless you
know let's have a [ __ ] heart attack
when they're 55 years old right harder
to maintain the anger so it's like I
going to be funny without being as angry
as I was but I got honest to be as angry
as I was just life is good right what
that's the thing too but don't you
always find a little something to be
angry about what's great is thank God
something happens to me that day because
I'm sure you're like me where you'll go
up in your first five minutes or what
something in your act is going to be
about what happened that day because
you're like I can't even [ __ ] believe
my life is this hard yeah so even though
it's pretty freakin easy so I think
we'll always have some anger it'll be
about sillier stuff and I think the
audience likes that too because it's
just stupid like today for some [ __ ]
reason okay okay seriously I'm so pissed
about this because it me
last night my freakin Amazon fire stick
was not working but I finally get the
[ __ ] thing to work then I switched to
my TV my cable isn't working my source
or so and I one or the other oh yeah
this is alright I'm Lisa Lampanelli I
should have to write but then I go oh
maybe use the TV in the other room like
you're such a douchebag but stuff you
get mad at and it's like thank God I
have one of those two at one time how
could I not catch up on orange is the
new black I just started watching that
by the way [ __ ] season 1 episode 3
dude I'm on season 2 we're far behind
can I tell you it is the best show ever
unbelievable it gets really dark and
really good yeah and how hot is the
woman to transsexual Laverne Cox I met
her in the lobby they on the way out one
day we interview laura Prepon who's
going Taryn oh no Aaron Manning the
Cartman I'm sorry I Oh Taylor Schilling
Callie's chillin sorry she's cool tool
Iselle on the way out oh I see Laverne
Cox and so I said hello I want to take a
photo yeah and you know she's lovely in
person shiny United from the Mia
Isabella interview she's like oh I know
yo yo really yeah yeah I interviewed her
I think I've interviewed her twice but
the last time she was up here she we
just passed by each other in the hall
and she was just like oh hello there
oh no I know I was excited that's so
funny because you can't be getting that
a lot why you think come on look at us
we all know we're not Jim Norton hot
we're definitely another guys hot dog
you know what do you get in on while
you're Mary get hit on never I've never
been oh I don't know me neither people
go to me cuz I've been celibate for four
and a half years have you really oh yeah
I've only been divorced two and a half
which might say something about why I'm
not want to have sex with him I just
didn't want sex in general because I
went through menopause and I think I
don't think I'm still going through it
but the sexual urges haven't come back
have you looked at women at all or no no
and guess what I don't even jerk off I
have no feeling from the waist down and
I love it four years four and a half
Jesus and I'll tell you why that's great
that would cloud up my head like someone
who told me lust is the enemy because
honestly you can concentrate on what
you're doing if you got straight in your
life you don't have to chase meaningless
relationships and have sex with
meaningless guys so I think what's going
to happen this is what I think how I'm
getting
I think what's going to happen it's
going to reawaken at some point when I
meet an appropriate guy because at these
these co-dependent relationships I had
is no good based on looks and lust it
should be based on you know who your
equals are it's actually cool it's
really crazy yeah but I focus on like
what the genitals are going to look like
right like all these crazy things then I
start to look at the person like it's
just it's very well go the appropriate
like you meet the person you like them
and then you write it is hard to shift
it and now that I have no feelings about
it well what's funny too is people like
a clone that can't be true and inside
I'm going you know I'm kind of like Sam
like where are the offers coming from we
get no offers no offers none that's I
mean I would never get divorced because
I don't have options no I was brave
enough to get a divorce but I still
don't have option I think I put up a
wall - I'm very nice in real life Jim
Norton knows this I'm a sweetheart of a
gal I walk around my town I'll be very
nice to people but I think there's an
imaginary wall up of like she's not
having it that's my favorite part about
being married is that like when you're
married since you're not going to pursue
anybody I have this confidence of
literally any girl that talks to me in
the back of my head I'm like oh yeah
she's flirting yeah a little bit yeah I
got a shot there
you never have to you never have to
figure out whether you do or don't
there's never going to be any proof so
you can just trick yourself into
thinking you have a shot with everybody
yeah that's true but I'll have a guy at
Home Depot for instace help me put my
plants in the car yeah and all of a
sudden I'll be scared that he likes me
and I'll just be like thanks man like I
saw a girl I was really good thanks dude
so I think my next play I write I'm
going to do about women and
relationships because I'm [ __ ] up I
don't know what I'd be so mad though
there was married to somebody who two
years into the marriage decided like now
I'm going to be celibate now no I didn't
decide it what I decided was what would
menopause you kind of don't have a
choice but you could take hormone
replacement so I was like I'm really not
into sex that much up first of all Jim I
don't do it very good you know what I'm
saying I don't know pretty terrible I
think why do you think you allowed a
fake it I do do not not orgasm I think I
faked enjoying it
I'm one of those people was born sort of
asexual used sex to be in a relationship
because I was serial monogamists from 13
to about not each other no and um I
think I kind of just kind of used it to
get the guy to date me and then I sort
of go through the motions and now I
don't really know if I'm very good at it
did you ever have any but I have to ask
this because also say you have anybody
fumble with you and you were young but
you know no no I think that's a problem
I didn't feel like I was wanted as a
child with others I realize no but what
was funny is in that food we had they
asked all the girls you know who's been
who had inappropriate sexual contact as
a child everyone reads her head except
me and I was like oh great great
well even I make a joke about this on
page but this is true I had the only
date rapist on campus who took no for an
answer
I do this was so he was a varsity
basketball player I'll never forget it
hot hot white guy and I went out with a
date with him and people said he's a
date rapist I go I don't care he's
pretty long never know so we go out and
he starts being inappropriate he goes I
mean it was very haunting now that I
think about it and you know he goes
you're lucky but tonight I'm not in the
mood to to force myself he goes but
usually I don't take no for an answer
and I'm like come back mr. Cosby no I
don't know but if that really happened I
was like serving on multiple love right
in a sense that what could have happened
and then in the sense why didn't it
happen
yeah kind of like hurt yeah thank God it
really didn't you know why did you go
out with him to begin with that's that's
a big question a lot there's a lot wrong
with the whole scenario yeah they're
like why do you mean you know date I
gotta figure myself out dude you would
have asked for it but but it in happened
I know I did I think right now it's
enough working on myself like that's why
I say if I work on myself enough to
attract somebody who's amazing but
that's the way it's going to go and it's
not going to have to do with lust or
looks or money it'll just have to look
like oh you know this is somebody I'm
supposed to be with how very any dates
no I don't bother with it you don't know
again who's asking I I honestly do yeah
you know what kind of spiritual leader
do you have I have a I go to this place
called Craigh Paulo it's a meditation
retreat place and yoga retreat
up in the Berkshires and honestly it's
so great it's super spiritual but you
can get into it as much or as little as
you want
like they say meditate phenomenal with
this meditation I can't do it I don't
know I do 10 minutes a day if I'm lucky
from a nap
I'm not that kind of chick and I tried
yoga I can't do no yoga I fall over I
don't want like a [ __ ] [ __ ] in
front of these chicks I'm famous how
dare you so I have people who I just
talked to about these issues yeah why
are one I used to have a therapist now
it's more spiritually based but he
combines everything I see you know do
you pray to God or not that kind of push
on it no not really not for me I mean
it's more like I just kind of think
things through
go internally and go feel your feelings
a big thing Jim as you know with
addiction and mine was food and Men is
to just feel your feelings they're not
going to kill you like that whole thing
of you know just test not using cake
once and honestly then you have the
history to prove you don't need the cake
it's still going to be a struggle the
next time but you have history to prove
that you don't need it what was your
relationship like with because you did a
Celebrity Apprentice yeah so what was
your relationship like with Trump when
you did that and like how how many years
ago was it it was like five years ago or
maybe more oh my god probably seven is
it weird to think you've interacted with
the president but yeah but who the hell
would have ever thought that's what we
said he was going to run for president
it was one like a child says they want a
pony for Christmas like it's not going
to happen huge bag but trouble is always
good to me and this legitimately
happened okay ever since he got you know
was running got presidents of here's
what happened I get calls from reporters
going was he sexually inappropriate to
anyone was he did you see anything dude
no but this was so funny and insulting
at the time by the way when that Billy
Bush tape came out you must have had
flashbacks to college again my [ __ ] and
balls got in the way but with this Trump
this thing actually happened he would go
around I think this had helped lead to
the surgery eventually because I go wow
I'm really invisible because I had the
weight on he would go around the room
before the cameras went on he's a
compliment a different woman ever taping
so he'd go you know to Rizzo you look
beautiful day over you look more
attractive with every week and honestly
of course he's going to leave me out I
was a battle-axe I wasn't his type
he looks at me one day and goes Lisa and
I got my hopes up a little bit everyone
wants to be noticed and he doesn't
Teresa look beautiful I'm like holy crap
yeah I do have a secret hidden penis
that he don't know but honestly it
didn't crush me but it goes can't Lisa
because every woman's going to get to
that point where you're invisible you're
either a handicapped woman fat old we
just disappear so I always say to these
[ __ ] under 30 if a guy bikes by you
now saying I want to come on your tits
saver that [ __ ] that's people all the
good old days there's no way they're
ungrateful see they have no idea man and
they're ungrateful by the way it does
end it does at least as promoting by the
way just to promote your promoting stuff
and it begins October the fifth tickets
are on sale now it insult comic calm or
stuffed play.com and it's going to be a
at the Westside theater which is on 40
Thursday which is an awesome point have
you seen things that I've been there
yeah yeah years ago The Vagina
Monologues started at that that theater
and Nora Ephron's play Lovelace on what
I wore so it's a theater that really
does these four to five woman shows
really well so with the communic after
three other actors talking about food
addiction weight you know body image
struggles etc but it's not morbid right
now it's not I would say the first 45
minutes are just dropped down funny and
they're hilarious
and then of course we get to the bigger
issues and the bottoms and we all had a
fall through but guess what the fact is
if you're a comic yeah the funny Alan
Zweibel helped me write this this was an
SNL you're at the whole thing yeah what
did you write the whole thing or just
your part no no I wrote the whole thing
did ya and Alan Zweibel was like a
co-writer on it and he said Lisa don't
worry about the funny with Billy
Crystal's show he told Billy don't be
don't worry you're going to be funny
just write the real stuff first and I
think that helped me get the surgery too
it led to the fact that I eventually
dealt with my food issues and decided to
get the surgery so yeah the place great
man we had an off-broadway run now it's
going to the West Side run for like six
months at least I'm like holy crap well
at celebrity cast it's going to be
really gangster did you say who is in it
already or not yet that's like an ounce
in a couple months all okay yeah October
5th preview start and tell a charge calm
Jim I always want to say that yeah
like Hamilton typing put it this way
this is off Broadway's equivalent of
Hamilton without more than one black we
could put one black or an Asian in in
order to be racially correct in these
days and age sure and there are some
different races that have these food
issues as we've seen so you know think
about it Laverne Cox you might be have
to be in my play for me so that's a
whole different different surgery so you
don't get you don't get [ __ ] from like
colleges or like anger driven stuff from
them about stuff you say listen these
colleges I've never done college I did
three in my whole life I always said I
don't want to change a word that I say
three colleges agreed to that in my holy
career and it's great but they don't
even pay that much like remember they
pay a lot years ago and you go if you
want me to edit that'll cost you a lot
more and I'm not having bravado yeah I
mean you understand we just don't want
to change what we do corporates I've
done maybe three also yeah I have one
cancel on me oh my god this was the best
it was I'm not going to say whom but a
very famous athletic wear company wanted
me to do this big corporate for them
with John Legend so you know it's going
to be like a big thing yeah they cancel
it because the guy who had booked it
didn't share who it was in my comedy
until like right at the last minute dude
I got the money
Wow how great is that when you could
make Bank bro like I used to say about
greg Giraldo before gobblers guy dresses
all I used to say they pay you not to be
on TV they pay me not to do gigs I loved
sitting home and going suck my dick
whatever underarmour thing type of thing
they found out what you didn't felt like
in a corporate environment would be bad
but I will give you the check but just
that was fan a half far before the gig
cuz corporates always a nightmare how
far before did you realize I don't have
to go do this oh my god I think it only
happened like two weeks before but what
was cool was that they paid it because
part of me goes I you can really fight
them and you know sometimes you're not
going to win like a couple months ago I
got mad because I booked a couple before
the play starts because we start
rehearsal in September I booked a bunch
of clubs in order to try new stuff for a
special because you know you're not
going to do that in front of the theater
sure so I booked this one club dude I
walk up to that place I don't work up
come on let's be honest I'm I was driven
up to that day
and I tell you what this thing had not
one picture of me I was very sad and
depressed because I go it's not going to
sell out if you don't know I'm here yeah
y'all I feel weird
tried to get them to try to beat more
money out of them because that's what
the agents try to do it didn't work but
at least you like try when you when you
realize something didn't sell out and
I've had those two raising when did that
happen
like well you said you did Radio City
and Carnegie Hall when did you when did
something like while I'm doing this club
but it didn't sell tell you exactly what
happened and it hurt my feeling so bad
that's why I wrote the play Pittsfield
Massachusetts I will never forget they
have a small theater it sold out there
last time I did it which is a good
lesson but years about seven years ago
when I started writing this play I
didn't sell out Pittsfield Massachusetts
I think it was 800 seats on the Thursday
night first of all I forgot that it was
a Thursday so I took it to personally
for a Thursday but I remember looking at
Jimmy and I got tears in my eyes I can't
[ __ ] sell out Pittsfield Massachusetts
on a Thursday I'm retiring I can I
retired he goes you can do whatever you
want that's always great about him he
really didn't care about money or
anything so I'm out of here
like what do I care I already did
everything I wanted to in comedy I don't
care the next day I wake up I'm watching
HBO I see Carrie Fisher doing her
one-person show and I go that's what I'm
going to do I'm going to write a play
so Jimmy big-balls wakes up around noon
which was his type of thing and I go
guess what I'm writing a play and you
put your [ __ ] retiring last night I
go no no I'm not I'll never retire so I
start working on the play and it's ready
so that's what happens it leads you to
what you're supposed to be led to and
the big lesson is last time I was in
Pittsfield it sold out it did so I think
you just got to go I'm going to sell out
some places I'm not going to sell out
others like I will never sell out Dallas
I don't know why never I don't know why
it's I think theaters maybe 2,000 or
2,500 it doesn't work you that's been a
city you've never sold it don't get it I
have 90 of those I do know what you mean
there's some places no matter how well
you doing that one city reminds you this
yeah and happen that's the one who got
away
I will accept not selling out in a red
state that there's no gays like you
Gallus there's gays
you're trying to come out
I just can't accept Alice it hurts my
feelings and then you go eh
you know what that's where you got to
shift into spirituality mode would just
go
whoever supposed to see this well and
then you'll get a nice email from
somebody saying like you know something
that helped them laughs and you feel
like I did my job because really it's
our job really about our ego when we
take the ego out of it it doesn't matter
like you bet our feelings would never
get hurt if it wasn't for ego yeah that
is the true I mean I I hurt my own
feelings over nonsense I know I do give
ya over what over like what she's
talking about we kill ourselves over
like not selling out in certain cities
yeah and Twitter followers and this and
that I have over half a million Twitter
followers and I'm I finally got like a
hundred thousand yeah but here's the
deal none of mine are real I bet because
they all were fans during that no no no
no not that but I think during The
Apprentice they like me now they're kind
of oh yeah because I don't get no
responses I get maybe a hundred
responses to a tweet it used to be the
old days was like a thousand because it
was the apprentice is that ego you know
what this is the place I'm supposed to
be so I have to talk myself out of that
ego thing a lot and it's funny too
because like unlike look at the other
end of that that's because the
apprentice was such a huge driver I
interviewed you're a big it wasn't a
apprentice and then you go forward you
know you look at where you're at now but
you look at where the apprentice is now
nobody's watching nobody on that well I
had been be argued that I killed that
show right here we talked about the
apprentice last week my manager she's so
awesome and we're going did the
apprentice do anything for my career
literally nothing that's what happened
and it didn't hurt it at all no I meant
in my reputation as a badass but did
nothing it earned 130 grand for my
charity which is great but Jesus great
that's not why I did the show right
there all those kunti celebrities are
like I'm doing it for my charity no
you're doing it cuz you're a [ __ ]
loser with a dream you like don't think
about it but it really didn't do
anything except guess what it did Jim
put if frickin got me recognized on the
street so much but then I get the weight
loss surgery nobody recognizes it's like
the universe's way of saying Jesus
Christ get the ego out yes who don't
need it you don't look like you from The
Apprentice anymore yes I look so
freaking beautiful well I don't know
it's
Jim I'd say that and I oddly believe it
well I don't know what's wrong with me
part of me feels that it's okay that I
shop at forever 21 and H&M I go there's
something wrong with me that I think I'm
19 years old but I don't care it's not
like I'm thinking oh I'm being more
beautiful than that person I'm like I
look better than I did ten years ago
[ __ ] it yeah why is that one of the
reasons why you shaved off all your hair
and everything it made like a very
stylistic choice because I said did Katy
Perry do it Lisa Lampanelli Cyrus but I
think it's because you just go let it go
like I talked to Jon Cryer in the
greenroom he's terrific he has a shaved
head now he goes I was balding I don't
like it
hey this is so much easier that's part
of the reason do you they let it go kind
of like frozen oh do you have kids I
have a little for months though don't
worry lovely effect so he'll put it
daddy
yeah there you go what happened with the
Westboro Baptist Church all right those
evil [ __ ] they really are awful are you
no audience oh my god God hates [ __ ]
calm oh no I love the [ __ ] here's what
happened to me Jim I'll tell you the
full story I'm playing someplace near
them I think Wichita Topeka they tweet
out that they're going to protest me so
here I'm such a [ __ ] I go oh really
well let me get back at them
I said good show up [ __ ] more the
merrier because everybody who shows up
to protest me I am donating a thousand
dollars of my own money to the gay men's
health crisis in New York City so I
figure nobody's going to show up because
they don't want me doing that you know
[ __ ] them pay for your let's really
[ __ ] 48 of them show I uh need twenty
would show up so twenty grand that's
that's nice
well his 48th show up so I tweet out the
next day because it got on CNN I tweet
out Oh [ __ ] forty-five years showed
up cuz I thought I did an accurate count
yeah well it was Jimmy big balls
counting and he's not so good with the
number he's not so I say okay I'm going
to up it to 50 and I gave him 50 grand
there nothing that feels better than
hand you know they had one of those big
cardboard checks made out and then it to
somebody
except when they hand it to you it's
pretty a lot better a lot better dude
that
also good animal song it's 50 grand what
are we going to do that would be the
charity for the year so I think after
that I didn't buy no clothes for I'll
[ __ ] it will you just do it you just do
a Rogen interviewed one of the they're
losing a lot of their younger members
yeah I heard ah because it'll pop
cultural and stuff you just can't keep
people from seeing without their right
and I forget which one of us she's a
cute I might have been negative ELPS
Megan Roper Phelps but Joe just had a
rod I have I haven't seen the podcast
but I think I kind of slowly going
I hope yeah guess what man died fresh
multi yeah so that was so happy but I
just couldn't believe that really exists
because first of all God expects calm
best name ever I wish I thought of it
because that would be my web really
isn't marketable name it really yeah
yeah I'm going to just add gone eh jinx
but you know they're very organized
those Asians have you learned that today
don't [ __ ] around when it comes to being
socially outraged yeah they'll get it
yeah well my opening act now is a gay
guy who used to be on Sirius name Frank
de Caro oh yeah yeah he was on out cue
for many years he says he goes you know
I love my people but we get upset over
everything he goes I'm so sick of every
time I turn around
we gays have another [ __ ] protest
going because he goes he at one point
they wanted them to not shop in Target
and for a gay guy that's like life life
and I was like they could change the
name of target to [ __ ] you you fat
[ __ ] and I would stop because there's
some things groups just get outraged
over everything now and like I said to
you hey if my career goes down the
toilet eventually because they don't
want politically incorrect then it's
done so much ass William yeah okay and I
like to think I gave people don't
honestly want to live without
chick-fil-a they don't like I got no
good dude it is the best anti tour with
this rag and I said when Frank we're
going to a chick-fil-a
and then I'll go to Taco Bell and said I
go good go have the [ __ ] I'm going to
chick-fil-a I'm Christian you are and
isn't it funny they're still not open on
Sunday those chick-fil-a I know they're
not
I really only get a Bible verse with
every fry yeah hey you uh what do you
think about like good because Elijah
just kind of stepped in [ __ ]
iliza shlesinger what happened all you
didn't yell no saying that you female
comics she was challenging female comics
but he basically said that yeah I think
she said I the she's the only female
comic with like a history joke the
meaning that and that
and she walks into a club and can't tell
the difference between which female
comic is performing they're all just
telling jokes about their vaginas and
and all that and kind of pointed herself
out as somebody who's not following this
sort of look never here's what you do as
a comic I've learned this hard lesson
that you will learn you never generalize
onstage of course for humor never say
I'm the first never say I'm the only
somebody's going to figure out somebody
who has that joke and you're going to
look like a jerk and have to apologize I
don't know if she's right
I have many history jokes myself black
history my own history with black buddy
what you think if I remember once Norm
Macdonald was on the radio and he said
something like there's no female comics
out there this is like five years ago
who acts female and at the time I what
he goes they go about least limit and go
she acts like a dude and I'm like yeah
he's right so you can't ever get really
really mad about stuff that you're
lumped in with but I don't know who'd
she get crap from just a lot of other a
lot of women ya know what you do you're
going to go you let it go guess what um
I do what I do am I the most original
person in the world maybe not to some
I'm totally me
that's how only person I could be they
say oh you ripoff Rickles I say I never
directly stole one of his jokes but if I
happen to have the same beautiful love
ability that he and Jim Norton have then
I have to deal with that right so yeah I
just learned in the business because you
know Joan Rivers God rest us all she
would be very mean about other female
comic was she oh she was terrible to me
Oh am in her book and I understood see
this is why it's lucky I was interviewed
about her years later after I worked on
myself if I can't come down on her
because guess what she was a dented cam
like the rest of us I think we're all
dented cans what did she say about you
oh not original she's oh no no I I was
quoted um you know she said on the air
that I was unoriginal that I only talked
about the blacks and this is years later
when that's not true and I go him get
mad I was hurt a little because she's an
icon sure I let it go comics have been
mean to me the whole time Jim remembers
they made me miserable to sell her I was
way too soft for the seller I would come
there bring a book and read because it
hurt me all the time so I always
look three people who will meanness to
me and this is true Patrice O'Neal greg
Giraldo Joan Rivers they all got one
thing in common they are in the [ __ ]
ground
guess who still up there is and so you
just gotta go with other comments just
shut your mouth did you know Patrice
felt bad about his relationship with you
he was ready to radio show and he
apologized and they played it these
pollen young Ron from Polly want the
whole weekend cuz no one could believe
Patrice O'Neal apologized and it was so
heartwarming that by the end he did that
I just thought that was real gentleman
Jeff Garlin tells a story similar to
that too he just at the end he was like
I've been that guy like you know you had
that moment yeah or that like wow that
moment of self-reflection that he wasn't
sick I mean it wasn't like he knew he
was gonna die but he just came to that
plant yes where he was like I'm [ __ ]
with people like and you forget that it
has a real effect on real people
well I remember is merely I mean it
really was what shut me down at the
cellar cause I remember the first time I
ever talked to retrieve was when I mean
so many years ago we were both kind and
newish but he was still he had been on
TV already on Conan his first big Conan
he comes in and there was nobody else
there so he talked to me so I was like
you know the loser who he talked to
and he goes was asking me something
about a girl that he liked and advice
and whatever remember coming in the next
day all you guys were there so he had
somebody else to talk to so I walk in
and like like the kid at school I just
go hi Patrice Ingles look just because
we talked once doesn't mean we're
friends do you know what that [ __ ]
doesn't even know you don't know anyone
else and you feel like oh my god shot me
down I was never comfortable to sell her
again I go every night til I started
doing theaters about 15 years ago I've
never been in the cellars and really or
any comedy club in the city not because
I don't want to die I never do spots I
don't want to do spots like my life
thank God is in Connecticut for the most
part we're really a family and we're
living both New York and Connecticut but
I don't feel like my time is well spent
to clubs it doesn't profit me but boy
did it hurt you know it hurts your
feelings they don't get your spill it's
all I did yeah I mean I think I've said
this on the air before but he was
Patrice was dismissive of Jess the first
time he met her what you know is my wife
girlfriend at the time
which he was of Girlfriends sure and
like years later this is a summer before
he died I had introduced her as if they
hadn't met before just kind of ease off
earnest right and he took full ownership
and apologized watch it right there and
like blue jazz and Jessa carried it for
years like knowing that like she wasn't
treated right now is like a hospital
like what we do carry and that's what's
great I remember when the New York New
Yorker magazine or New York was doing a
big retrospective on Patrice and it was
right after that's probably a month or
so in really deep piece and they were
interviewing everybody so they called me
for an interview and I go of course I
talked to Michael I [ __ ] hated him I
go yeah you apologized he [ __ ] ruined
about ten years of my life and of course
he was much now I know he was my best
teacher you know come on so I go he was
a horrible I go and he I go just because
he died doesn't mean I'm going to switch
my story and say he was a great guy so
what's great is it fit in with the story
great it was nice you know I get an
email from his wife I guess and she goes
you are the best
Patrice would have [ __ ] love that you
stuck to your guns like that and what's
funny is then I'm label it go write that
I know you don't like that they would
have said you were right I was shitty to
her yeah isn't it intrigued
you're always loved when he was shitty
to me because you always apologize
because he's a big [ __ ] [ __ ] like me
boss rich man would literally he'd say
something by the way anything he said to
you to tissue was so funny yeah that you
almost didn't care but he'd come up the
next day and those analogies okay though
[ __ ] right cuz you all AAA yeah and I'm
like he's also a coward
he got brave showers I thought I'd make
it and he wouldn't want to get on the
old gravy train but honestly I was like
that's really sweet but I always thought
like you know who I quote Jim Norton so
much and I can't believe it
because you know I always talk about
Seinfeld how we used to stop at the
cellar and just not be nice and just
kind of not and be like above it and
there's sort of not a nice guy but not
nasty but never friendly and Norton I
would said once to Norton you know a
[ __ ] times I don't think so the [ __ ]
he is huh and Norton said something to
me like he is who he is like he is that
guy he was that guy before he's going to
be that guy now he has a lot of
responsibility so but just he just being
who he is and that teaches you
tens of people they're not going to be
who you want them to be but I'm such a
[ __ ] weasel I was probably hoping it
would get back to Jerry yeah
co-defendant idiot but no he when you
see somebody who's consistently that
person you like okay that's who that
person is that's how they interact with
people it's worse when you see somebody
who starts out a certain way and then
goes through it and then all of a sudden
becomes a [ __ ] that's kind of fresh the
worst like uh well walks I said the same
thing about Daniel Tosh and I don't even
know if this true cuz I never met him
say he he's always been an [ __ ] and
he's still an [ __ ]
is he an Tosh one time you interviewed
me when they were doing before you had a
show he was doing some life stuff for
Comedy Central the festival in Florida
the only time I think I've ever
interacted with him right